- [Cameraman] You gonna
put on your light, pal?
That was nice.
- It was nice, really good.
(alternative rock music)
Vlog, I think it's a good episode actually
because it's a good
episode that speaks to, ah,
not everything always working out, right?
Tonight I was planning to do three,
four, five hours of live,
selling a shitload of books,
but then between some
family stuff and the team,
we decided I was gonna go
to the office and I didn't.
Logistics didn't work out.
We met at a pizza shop where
I thought I could do it,
but then wifi didn't
work, I couldn't go live.
So we just had a little
impromptu kinda one-hour meeting,
Irish Alex, Tyler, Tyler,
Andy, and D-Rock and I.
(camera shutter snaps)
Like it's so black and white obvious!
- [Man] I mean, YouTube.
- Like look at me, we're gonna cry,
we're gonna sit here in three years
when there's nothing like it,
and we're gonna be like,
"Dude, what the fuck."
And then we came out here,
we drew the brunch out of
a bucket on the street.
The person that's joining us, for brunch,
on Monday 26th is.
And that's it, mission not accomplished.
Which is okay.
Just gotta get punched in the
mouth and move on to tomorrow.
Just did not accomplish what I wanted,
but I'm unfazed by it
and I think, you know,
about such a role we
haven't had an opportunity
to share those kind of moments,
And I think it will help a lot of you,
'cause a lot of viewers like to,
when doesn't it work out,
what didn't work out?
Today did not work out,
tonight did not work out.
Tomorrow's tomorrow.
I'm good.
- [Cameraman] But, we did find a dumpster.
- We did find another dumpster!
They fucking suck, they're
straight fucking trash,
that's why I fucking found a dumpster.
We did find another dumpster,
keep that high school
trash back in high school!
(indie rock music)